[موسيقى]
ام
السلام عليكم عبر رئيس الائتلاف السوري
المعارض احمد الجربا عن استعداد الائتلاف
لارسال ممثلين عن الى مؤتمر جنيف الثاني
الا ان كمال اللبواني عضو الائتلاف رفض
هذه التصريحات معتبرا انها لا تلزم
المعارضه السوريه من جهه ثانيه قال وليد
المعلم وزير الخارجيه السوري ان الحكومه
السوريه لن تقبل اي خطه نقل للسلطه الرئيس
بشار الاسد وهو ما يتعارض مع موقف
المعارضه السوريه بجميع مكوناتها التي كل
هذه الخلافات في وقت تحدثت فيه امين عام
الامم المتحده بان كي مون شهر نوفمبر
القادم موعدا تقريبا لعقد مؤتمر جنيف 2
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في المحورين
اثنين
هل يمكن ان تتفق المعارضه السوريه ال
منقسمه على نفسها بشان دفه وحده الى جنيف
وما هي سبل تجاوز الخلافات حول الثوابت
التي يفترض ان ينطلق منها تفاوض في مؤتمر
جنيف 2
بعد اطلاق مساري نزع السلاح الكيميائي
السوري حدد بان كي مون شهر نوفمبر القادم
موعدا تقريبا لعقد مؤتمر جنيف 2 من اجل
تسويه سياسيه شامله للازمه السوريه تفاؤل
لا يدعمه الواقع كثيرا خاصه في ظل
انقسامات لا تزال تعصف بالمعارضه السوريه
وتباين الاراء حول الثوابت التي يفترض ان
ينطلق منها الحوار
او 0 القادم هو موعد عقد مؤتمر جنيف الفا
من اجل السلام في سوريا حسب الامين العام
للامم المتحده
تاريخ يبدو قريبا لكن دونه تحديات كثيره
على مختلف الصعود السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
وبالطبع الميدانيه على الارض في سوريا
وزير الخارجيه السوري وليد المعلم اعلن
على هامش الاجتماعات السنويه للامم
المتحده ترحيب حكومته في المؤتمر وقال
انها ستذهب جنيف للحوار مع المعارضه
الوطنيه المرخصه كما وصفها وليس من اجل
تسليم السلطه لاحد
رئيس الائتلاف السوري المعارض احمد الجربا
اكد ايضا عقب اجتماعه مع الامين العام
للمنظمه الدوليه عزم الائتلاف رساله
ممثلين عنه للمؤتمر لكن معارضين اخرين
بينهم مقاتلون داخل سوريا اعلنوا رفضهم
لاي محادثات ما دام نظام الرئيس بشار
الاسد قائما وتحدث قادتهم عما وصفوه بعجز
الائتلاف يتوقع ان توضع في المؤتمرين
المرتقب ترتيبات تلزم مختلف الاطراف من
اجل الوصول لنهايه للصراع الدموي الراهن
بكل التفاصيل التي تحسن جدليات مالي
السلطه وشكل الوضع الانتقالي وصلاحياته
ومستقبل سوريا و يتبادر الى الذهن هنا وفي
خضم الضبابيه التي تملا المسافه نحو
انعقاد المؤتمر مواقف الدول الداعمه
للمعارضه ومنها الموقف الامريكي وطالما
صرح الرئيس باراك اوباما بان الحرب في
سوريا لن تنتهي الا برحيل الرئيس الاسد
وتخفض للاذهان ايضا تفاصيل اتفاق متمردين
في السابق الذي يروج ل حوار وطني يشارك
فيه الجميع مع تشكيل وضع الانتقاليه يحفظ
البلاد من الانهيار دون تطرح الاسد حينها
دعت موسكو لتبني الاتفاق بمجلس الامن
واصرت واشنطن لا رفاق ذلك بعقوبات على
نظام واطاح الجبل بينهما حول الامرين في
النهايه بالاتفاق تاجلت الدعوه المتمردين
في الثاني كثيرا رغم القناعه بان الحوار
والدبلوماسيه هما الطريق الاقرب لحل
الازمه وليست القوات العسكريه
وسيشكل المؤتمر في حال انعقاده طبعا
اختبارا حقيقيا
لنتائج معطيات وتداعيات اكثر من عامين
ونصف من الصراع الدموي
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع الدكتور كمال
اللبواني عضو الهيئه السياسيه في ائتلاف
قوى المعارضه والثوره السوريه الذي ينضم
الينا من اسطنبول وكذلك ينضم الينا عبر
سكايب من ميلتين تايمز في انجلترا الناشط
السياسي السوري عمار وقاف ومعنا هنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور غسان شبانه الرئيس من
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه ماري مونت
الامريكيه نبدا معك دكتور البلد اللبواني
و تلك التصريحات مسار الجدل والتي احدثت
زوبعه ان صح التعبير اعلاميا بدايه نود ان
نعرف هل تمت مناقشتها مع السيد ال جربه اه
ام انك طرحتها اعلاميا مباشره
اولا اليوم ظاهره علينا المعلم وهو متغطرس
ويقول ان الاستباقي بدل ان يفتح معابر
انسانيه الى الغوطه المحاصره اليوم وفورا
وبدل ان يوقف قصف الطيران يقول لنا ان
القاتل سيبقى وان المعارضه الوطنيه
العميله هي التي تفاوض وانه سيقاتل
الارهابيين وهذا يعني رساله غطرسه لا نقبل
بها لذلك نحن نقول هذا النظام لا يفهم الا
لغه القوه
فتح الحوار مع هذا النظام اعطاء شرعيه له
واعطاء مبرر للمزيد من القتل نحن نريد ان
يفهم المجتمع الدولي اننا الائتلاف الوطني
صمم ل يخدم الثوره السوريه التي تقول
باسقاط النظام ومحاكمه رموزه هذا هو مطلب
الثوره الائتلاف مفوض على تحقيق هذا
المطلب نحن اذا ارادوا ان يذهبوا الى جنيف
فيجب عليهم ان يعدلوا صياغه الائتلاف يعني
ان يحصلوا على سبعه وسبعين صوت ميه
واربعطاشر لا يجوز لرئيس الائتلاف او
لغيره ان يذهب هكذا بدون بدون ان ياخذ
قرار من الثوار اولا الذي يخوض للاختلاف
هم الثوار الحقيقيون على الارض هم الذين
يجب ان يقولوا لنا اذهبوا بسقف كذا وكذا
يعني
بما الناس حتى نفهم فقط ايضا المشاهد
الكريم ما تفضلت به من رفض نذهب لجنيف وان
السيد الجلبه يجب ان بل هو يتحدث عن نفسه
فقط هل هذه وجهه نظره يتقاسمها مع الكثير
من اه اعضاء الائتلاف اه ام انها وجهه
نظرك انت مثل ما هي وجهه نظر السيد الجلبه
فقط اه وعبر عنها كما قلت
انا انا اعتقد ان الائتلاف يخضع لضغوط وهو
لم يعد قادرا على حمايه اهداف الثوره ولا
ثوابت الوطن بدا مسيره التفريط واصبح غير
قادر على تمثيل الثوره لذلك ما يجري الان
هو ضغوط هائله على الثوره لكي تقبل
بالاستسلام للاسد من اجل تنفيذ المصالح
الايرانيه والروسيه والاسرائيليه
والامريكيين في المنطقه وليس اراده الشعب
السوري التي قالها صراحه انا واحد من
الناس لا اقبل تفويض الامن الشعب السوري
ومن السوار الذين يقاتلون دفاعا عن ام لا
عن بيوتهم واهلهم نحن نرفض رفضا قاطعا
الذهاب الى اي جهد دولي قبل ان يتحمل
المجتمع الدولي مسؤوليته اتجاه معاقبه
مجرمي الحرب تجاه حمايه المدنيين
اذا هم فاعلون اذا هم قادرون لا يضغطوا
علينا يضغط على المجرم وروح يعقبه اما ان
يحولوا القضيه الى قضيه في حوار وحوار
والشعب يقتل والناس محاصره و تموت من
الجوع هذا الطريقه في التعامل مع الشعب
السوري معينه ولا نقبل ها على الاطلاق
الشعب السوري يموت من الجوع يحاصر يقتل كل
يوم فك الحصار يدعموا الناس اعطوا غذاء
اعطوا سلاح يبدعوا الطيران يقصف الناس هذه
الخطاب الذي نسمعه
هل نحن الان وفقا لا تقول ان توافق ما ذكر
السيد جربه انما انقسام حقيقي داخل
الائتلاف الوطني السوري انه وجهات نظر
مختلفه يصلون في نهايه الامر الى نقاط
مشتركه تذهبون بها الى جنيف
انا لم اسمع السؤال جيدا لكن اريد ان اقول
ان الدبلوماسيه الموجوده اليوم ليس لديها
اي ضمانات على الاطلاق يعني المجتمع
الدولي فشل خلال سنتين الدول العربيه فشلت
خلال سنتين من تقديم اي شيء كيف تعتمد
عليهم وهم فاشلون سنتين من الفشل انا لا
اثق فيهم انا لا اثق الا بقدره الشعب
السوري على الاطاحه بهذا النظام انا من
الناس الذين يقولون علينا الثبات والصبر
لكي ننجز ثورتنا واهدافنا بايدين اولا
نعتمد على ضمانات احد ولا وعود احد مخزونا
مرارا وتكرارا وبالتالي انا غير واثق بانه
هذه الاراده الدوليه ستحقق الا مصلحه
اسرائيل في المنطقه دعني اتحول الان ربما
الى وجهه نظر اخرى تحديدا عبر السكايب
والسيد اه عمار وقاف صحيح ان اه هناك
تباين في تصريحات المعارضه كما قد يصفها
البعض لكن هناك تباين ايضا في اه اصوات
عديده تصدر من اه النظام السوري اليوم اه
سيد المعلم يتحدث عن بقاء الاسد وعن
امكانيات ترشحه وغير ذلك لكن سمعنا اصوات
اخرى بالفعل تتحدث عن ان اه
اه لا حسم عسكري مثلا فاروق الشرع منذ
تسعه الى عشره اشهر تحدث عن ذلك قدر
الجميل تحدث ايضا انه من الضروري الحديث
اه مع المعارضه الامر الذي سمعنا عكسه
تماما اليوم من قبل السيد وليد المعلم
يعني لا يوجد تعارض بين
الاستوديو الرئاسه القادمه وما بين مساله
عدم قدره على الحسم العسكري من من القدره
ومن المساله التي تذكرها الجميل وهي موضوع
الحوار الحقيقه يعني ليست متعارضه فيما
بينها هناك كثير من السوريه
متعدده عفوا عندما يتحدث البعض عن ضروره
الجلوس الى المعارضه السوريه والبعض الاخر
يلغي تماما هذه المعارضه والائتلاف تحديدا
ويتحدث عن معارضه في الداخل اه فقط اه
احزاب يرى البعض انها معارضه شكليه في
الاصل السيد وليد المعلم هو قال انه لا
يريد التحدث مع المعارضه ولم يكن ذلك
اعتقد بانه عندما هو يركز على الاحزاب
التي هي موجوده في الداخل السوري هو يقول
من حيث المبدا بانها هذه لديها ربما جمهور
في الداخل نحن وجدنا على سبيل المثال
بانها الائتلاف المعارض يعني يتم التخلي
عنه من قبل الناس التي هي موجوده على
الارض وتحمل السلاح في بيانين تقريبا شغل
اه اه يعني في اليوم في اليومين الثلاثه
الماضيه تقريبا شمال كافه الفصائل ال يعني
المسلحه على الارض
اه يستطيع تستطيع الحكومه ان تقول الان
لاي شخص من الائتلاف يريد ان يحضر هذا
المؤتمر انت من تمثل بالتحديد هناك اه انت
تمثل ما تقول بانهم فور طيب هؤلاء الثوار
يقولون انت كانت لا تمثله الفكره ليست هي
القبول بهذا الشخص الشخص او هذا الائتلاف
المعارض او هذا الفصيل المعارض هي الفكره
ببساطه شديده يعني بالنسبه ل من وجهه نظر
الحكومه السوريه اعتقد بانه اذا انا جلست
مع شخص واتفقت معه على اتفاق ما ما هي
قدره هذا الشخص على تنفيذ هذا او بنود هذا
الاتفاق ما هي قدرته على التاثير على
الارض اعتقد ان هذه هي المساله يعني ان
كان للائتلاف السوري المدعوم طبعا خليجيا
ومليون دوليا من كثير من البلدان ليس له
القدره على ضبط مثلا العناصر المسلحه على
الارض الاجتماع هو الحكومه على الرغم من
ذلك يعني اعتقد ان الحكومه السوريه حسب ما
فهمت يعني من وسائل الاعلام في اليومين
الماضيين وقبلها ايضا لانها هي ما تم
بالجلوس مع الجميع لكن من اراد احيانا هو
طرح ربما بعض اه الشروط المسبقه يعني نحن
نريد كذا والا للمجلس نحن نريد كذا حقيقه
الامر ما راينا خصوصا في الاسابيع الماضيه
من تحول في الموقف الدولي ما رايناه من اه
تخلي ال
العناصر المسلحه عن السياسيين في الخارج
هو لو ببيان قد يعتبره البعض ما قد يعتبره
البعض شكليا يعني لا يعطي الكثير من الحقل
هذا الائتلاف او لهذه العناصر السياسيه
ربما نناقشه مع الدكتور غسان اه سمعت لما
قال هو كلا الطرفين هناك من الواضح كما
الكثير من الرسائل متناقضه
اه بخصوص التمثيل الانقسام بخصوص المجتمع
الدولي كيف
اعتقد يعني بقلق شديد لانه حينما تاتي الى
اه حل اه نزاع ما في العالم واعترف بان
الطرفين منقسمين على انفسهم وترى بان هناك
لا يوجد رساله واضحه من كلا الطرفين اعتقد
بان المجتمع الدولي سوف يكون لديه يعني اه
شكوك كبيره في كيفيه السير قدما ولكن
اعتقد ان الائتلاف السوري في هذه الفتره
استفاد استفاده كبيره من قرار مجلس الامن
الدولي الذي صدر ليله الجمعه صباح السبت
وهو رقم ثلاثه 118 لماذا اعتقد بانه الان
اصبح جزء لا يتجزا من القانون الدولي ال
القيام بجنيف كينيا يتجزا من القانون
الدولي الانتقال بالسلطه من بشار الاسد
الى سلطه تحكم ذات صلاحيات واسعه وموسعه
اه اصبح جزءا لا يتجزء من القانون الدولي
بان تقوم روسيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومجلس الامن الدولي بالوقوف على
مثل هذا الانتقال لذلك اعتقد بان الثوره
السوريه الان بدات بدات تاخذ منحى اخر من
ناحيه القانون الدولي والعلاقات الدوليه
بمعنى ان مجلس الامن الان لديه باع كبير
وسوف تتدخل تدخلا مباشرا لانهاء هذا
الصراع سواءا بي اي طرف او شي ايضا بمعنى
انه لم تكن لم يعد هناك نظام الاسد الكثير
من ال ال اه القوه لرفض ما سوف يقرر عليه
وما سوف يفرض المعارضه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى نعم المعارضه هي منذ
البدايه صنفت على انها منقسمه يعني لانه
المعارضه هو ليس بجديد المشكله انا ال
الذي سمعت من الدكتور اللبناني هو ليس
بانقسام بل هو بل هو العوده الى الحاضنه
الشعبيه كي تعطي صوتها الرجل يقول الرجل
يقول بانها على احمد الجربي قبل الذهاب
الى جنيف 2 لان جنيف 2 لا يوفي بتطلعات
الشعب السوري وهذه وجهه نظر فيحترمها
الكثير عليه العوده الى الثوار على الارض
عليك العوده الى الشعب السوري الذي يعني
اعتقد بان الدكتور كمال كان يتكلم عن اه
بنفسه عن نفسه وانه يقول بان على الشعب
السوري ان يتحمل ويحرض نفسه بنفسه بذلك
الجمله اعتقد بانهم ويقول بان الصراع في
سوريا سوف يصير سبع الى عشر سنوات ونحن
مستعدين لان نتحمل ذلك لان المجتمع الدولي
خبرنا
اساس لها نقطه مهمه دكتور منذر الخاصه ب
اه ما يجري على الارض وتاثير هذه الفصائل
الموضوع الذي اشار اليها ايضا اه ضيفنا من
اسطنبول في هذا التسجيل الذي بث عبر
الانترنيت يظهر المقدم ياسر العبود وهو
احد مقاتلي قوه المعارضه ويتحدث عن الفجوه
الكبيره التي تفصل بين المعارضه السياسيه
في الخارج المعارضه على الجبهات في الداخل
نواصل النقاش
[موسيقى]
مره اخرى الى اسطنبول الدكتور كمان
الدكتور كمال يعني ناهيك عن الانقسامات اه
الواضحه او اختلاف وجهات النظر داخل
الائتلاف السوري الان هناك من الواضح فجوه
كبيره بين المعارضه السياسيه ممثله في
الائتلاف ومن يقاتلون على الارض وبالت
وبالتالي السؤال الكبير كيف يمكن ان يؤثر
كل ذلك على مجريات ما يجري التحضير اه لها
العام
يعني رسالتها واضحه جدا لن نتفاوض مع
القدره يعني العداله هي الطريق للسلام هذه
ليست شروط وهذه ليست عقبه بانها ضروره
ملحه نحن نتفاوض فقط مع سلطه اخرى غير هذه
السلطه اذا ارادوا لنا ان نتفاوض لياتوا
لنا سلطه اخرى لم تقتل الشعب السوري ولو
لم تعجب الناس ولم تقدم المدن عندها يفتح
باب السلام اذا كان المجتمع الدولي قادر
فلين حي الاسد وان ياتي لنا بسلطه اخرى
هذه شروطنا واضحه جدا مع هذا المجرم مع
وفد تشكل هذا المجرم لن نذهب ومن يذهب
سيحاكم هذه قضيه منتهيه الزوار الذين
يحملون السلاح على الارض والجمهور سالي
لنا واضحه جدا لا تخرج عن ثوابت الثوره
والا ستحاكمون ايضا انا التزم بما يقول
الزوار هذا رايي هاذي قناعتي وبالتالي
هناك فعلا ضروره للائتلاف لكي يعود لا هو
لا يعود الى الى صوره الائتلاف لتشكيلته
الحالي لا يستطيع ان يكون مؤتمر لا يمثل
فعلا الشارع وبالتالي هناك مشكله حقيقيه
في هذا الائتلاف يجب اصلاحها او ستذهب عنه
الشرعيه وسينقسم ويتشرط وتعود القرار لمن
يحمل السلاح الذي يدافع عن الارض هو اللي
هو صاحب السياده
هناك قضيه يجب ان لا يضغط على الائتلاف
وان لا ياخذ الى مكان ينهار التدخل الدولي
السافر والغزو الذي جرى عندما عندما فرضت
علينا وثيقه ان سوريا ليست عربيه وان
سوريا دوله اتحاديه لا يجب ان يتكرر هنا
نحن نرفض هذه الضغوط وس نعتبر ان
اشكر الدكتور طبعا تبقى فاصل قصير نناقش
بعده خلافات من نوع اخر هذه المره تتعلق
بالثوابت التي يفترض انطلق ان تنطلق منها
المفاوضات في جنيف 2
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش او يناقشوا بعد الفاصل
الثوابت التي يفترض ان ينطلق منها مؤتمرنا
في اثنين خاصه تلك المتعلقه باقصاء الرئيس
بشار الاسد من اي تسويه سياسيه نتحول طبعا
الى ضيفنا من لندن والسؤال عندما نسمع اه
وليد المعلم يتحدث عن ان اه الاسد باق وان
الشعب السوري هو من سيقرر من سيترشح
بالتالي من سينتخب هناك ما يطرح سؤال ما
مدى شرعيه من يطرح اه هذا الموضوع وبهذه
الطريقه خاصه ان علمنا والجميع يعلم بان
النصف الشعب السوري بات الان منازعات او
لاجئا عندما نعلم ايضا بان هذا النظام لا
يملك القدره ولا السيطره على اكثر من خمسه
وستين بالمائه من الارض السوريه
تقدم يعني كنا نسمع قبل بضعه اشهر بانه
النظام لا يمتلك القدره على ثلاثين
بالمائه فقط من الاراضي السوريه
الشعب السوري يعني صحيح هناك فيه انقسام
حاد
واستقطاب كبير بين افراد الشعب السوري على
مختلف طوائفهم وشر الحياه الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه ولكن اه نحن علم اليقين بان
هناك شريحه كبيره جدا تدعم الحكومه هي
تذهب الى اعمالها بشكل يومي تذهب الى
مستشفيات ها الى مدارسها الى جامعاتها
بشكل يومي هذه العمليه من الانخراط في
العمل اليوميه تحت الاطار الحكومه يعني
بان الحكومه السوريه الحاليه يحظى بشرعيه
على الاقل قسم كبير وها مو كافي من
السوريه
الاخر الكبير والان ايضا من الشعب السوري
اعتقد ان الحكومه الحاليه في سوريا هي
تبحث عن من يمثل وانا اعود هنا يعني حقيقه
اتفق مع مع السيد كمال اللبواني عندما
يقول باننا يجب ان نكسب شرعيه الناس الذين
تمثلهم وهذا الحكي صحيح يعني الحكومه
السوريه عندما تريد ان تجلس ودخول بانني
يريد ان اتفاوض من اجل ان اه يعني ان هي
هذه المعاناه وساهم في انهاء هذه المعاناه
مع من يمثلون الطرف الاخر او الناس في
سوريا الذين لا يريدون هذه الحكومه هناك
سوف يتم حديث عن اليات كيف يتم انتخابات
جديده ماهي القوى السياسيه الحقيقيه على
الارض يعني نحن هنا كقائد يعني ليس فقط
لكن من المجتمع الدولي
اه كان هناك قرار بتسويه سياسيه وانتقال
اه اه سياسي ل اه السلطه في مرحله لا يوجد
فيها بشار الاسد ماذا نضع بكل هذا الكلام
لم يتحدث احد في وثيقه مع عن هذا الكلام
ال ال ال قرار الامم المتحده قرار مجلس
الامن الذي يعني ا جيد في اه يعني قبل
ثمان واربعين ساعه يتحدث في ماده 17 ان
القوى التي سوف تذهب الى مثلا جنيف 2 يجب
ان تكون ممثله حقيقيه للناس في سوريا اولا
ويجب ان تكون مؤمنه بالحل السياسي ثانيا
هذان الشرطان وهما جدا ف يعني نحن لا
نعتقد بان اه الائتلاف ربما طبعا هذه ليست
اول مره يخرج رئيس الائتلاف بنظريه ما
ويقوم اعضاء في الاختيار في الائتلاف يعني
بنقضيها يحدث مع السيد احمد معاذ الخطيب
سابقا الى ما هنالك
نعم نعود الى ضيفنا هنا الدكتور منذر ما
الذي يقوله فعليا اه
المجتمع الدولي بخصوص هذه الثوابت تحديدا
دكتور غسان اه م ما يتعلق ببقاء بشار
الاسد وقد سمعت ما قاله ضيفانا اه على اه
يعني ال المعلومات التي اتى بها الاستاذ
عمار هي غير دقيقه اه بالنسبه لل فهم جنيف
وكيفيه التحول من جنيف 1 جنيف 2 نعم
المجتمع الدولي يطالب الاسد بارسال اه اه
فريق للتفاوض ويطالب المعارضه بارسال فريق
للتفاوض ولكن ال ال الكاتب بهذا القرار
وهو كوفي عنان والممثل الثاني الاممي الذي
اه اه اتى بعد خوف يعني الاحظ الابراهيمي
قلب بكل ثقه وبكل الحرب انه لا مستقبل
بشار الاسد في هذه السلطه الانتقاليه ذلك
يعني يوجد فهم صريح اه اه وفق المعايير
الدوليه على ان بشار الاسد لن يكون له اي
دور في هذه الحكومه الانتقاليه التي يجب
ان توفر المناخ
انتخابات عادله يشارك فيها جميع افراد
الشعب السوري لذلك يعني لا اعتقد بان هذا
يعني فهم واضح حقيقه الى ما الى ما تقوله
او اذا الى ما يطلبه جنيف 2 هذا من ناحيه
من الناحيه الثانيه يعتقد بان قرار مجلس
الامن كان واضحا جدا ايضا بان لا يكون
هناك ان لا يكون هناك الكثير من افراد
السلطه الحاليه ومن افراد النظام اي دور
العبوه لماذا اقول ذلك لانه يوجد اه اه
فاصل في او او بند في هذا القرار يقول
بانه يجب ان يحاكم الكثير من المسؤولين عن
العمليات التي العمليات الاجراميه او
جرائم الحرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه التي
قاموا بها في سوريا لذلك يعني حينما نرى
مثل هذه البنود في مثل هذا القرار من هو
المقصود المقصود بان نظام ومن حوله سوف
يحاولون الى محاكم العدل الدوليه والمحاكم
الجنايات الدوليه لذلك يعني لا مجال لاي
لبس على الاطلاق على الاطلاق بان النظام
ومن حوله سوف يحاولون اما الى المحاكم
واما الى النفي واما الى ان لا يكون لهم
على الاطلاق اي دور يلعب في مستقبل سوريا
ال اه المدنيه القوى الديمقراطيه المدنيه
القادمه ذلك يعني هذا يجب ان يكون واضحا
وصريحا والمجتمع الدولي الان مجتمع على
مثل هذه الافكار مائه بالمائه عندما تستمع
اه دكتور غسان لما ذكره الدكتور كمال
اللبواني بخصوص بانه لا يجب ان يكون هنالك
تفاوض لا يجب ان اه ان يذهب اي فريق الى
جنيف 2
عندما نسمع على العكس من ذلك على النقيض
من ذلك اصوات ان تحدث السيد الجربه يقول
بانه سيوجد اه اشخاص الى هذا المؤتمر الذي
يمكن قراءته في ذلك هل نحن فعلا اذا
انقسام حقيقي اه ازاء تقاسم للادوار ام
يعني اعتقد بانه اذا
اكثر من الانقسام حقيقي لان الدكتور كمال
اللبواني يعارض بان يكون هناك الحاضنه
الشعبيه
ولا اعتقد بان الدكتور احمد الجربا يعرض
بان يكون هناك الحاضنه الشعبيه صوت في ال
في في مستقبل سوريا ولكن يعني الطرفان لا
يختلف ان على الاطار العام وهو الانتقال
بسوريا من الحل التي هي بها الى حاله افضل
بكثير وهي ديمقراطيه ومدنيه يعني هذا يعني
مهم جدا بان يكون هناك الاتفاق على الاطار
ولكن في التفاصيل يعني
الى ذلك هو ما يختلف عليه واعتقد بانه
اختلاف صحي جدا للغايه يعني لان يقول
الدكتور كمال هذا وان يقولوا دكتور احمد
الجربا ذلك يعني اه لا يصدق على الاطلاق
بالثورات ولكن قد يعطل على المسار الدولي
فهم بان ذلك انقساما وليس باتحاد وهو يعني
قد يعطل نوعا ما في اه الاجراءات القادمه
بالنسبه للمجتمع الدكتور
علينا رئيس قسم العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
الامارات الامريكيه كما نشكرك جزيل الشكر
ضيفنا من اسطنبول الدكتور كمال اللبواني
عضويه الاف قوى المعارضه والثوره السوريه
ونشكر جزيل الشكر الضيفان عباس تاييد من
ميسان كنت في انجلترا ناشط السياسيه
السوري عمار وقاف قياده انتهى هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]